we have long been hearing about one
important tool to fight the spread of
the coronavirus
contact tracing allows authorities to
respond when there's a new case
isolating those who've been near the
infected person the process is being
aided by technology that most of us
carry
and it's already showing results in
europe chris livesay
has the story in the united states
coronavirus is spreading like wildfire
and melissa thomas is stomping out the
embers calling on behalf of the new
haven health department
her mission is to break the chain of
infection by making a list of
everyone who encountered a patient as
she told cbs news back in may
then urging anyone who was exposed to
get tested
but imagine you're in a crowded street
and let's say i have coronavirus
how could i possibly notify all of these
people
once my test results come back well the
idea is
with an app you wouldn't have to
contact tracing apps are already being
used here in italy
germany and around europe thanks to a
rare collaboration by both google and
apple
the tech is free for any country to use
to develop its own app
using your phone's bluetooth signal it
can detect other phones that have
also downloaded the app if two users
come close enough
the phone records the data then later if
one of them tests positive for
coronavirus
the other will be notified of course
that's if the other person
also has the app marcus bechdahl writes
about tech in germany
he like most germans was skeptical at
first
privacy is a very strong value
even before germany south korea and
singapore started using
exposure notification but far more
invasively
those countries link infections to your
identity whereas the technology
developed by google and apple
does not there's no government database
it's just
phones talking to phones but so far
the u.s isn't using it dr tom frieden
the former director of the cdc
says there's no federal requirement to
contact trace
in the u.s we've really lacked a clear
national strategy
frieden also cautions that apps cannot
replace traditional contact tracing
but the really ambitious idea requires
that
a large proportion of people opt into
that app
requires that the bluetooth signal works
where you're at and requires that you
don't have false positives and false
negatives
now uptake in italy has been slow only
about four million downloads here
so far but germany's app has been
downloaded by 20
of the country amid a pandemic with few
solutions in sight
it's a start for cbs this morning
saturday
chris livesay rome